[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN MARTZ: Hello, hello.
How's it going, everybody?
Thank you so much for coming to
Developer Day at this GDC 2018.
I'm Nathan Martz.
I'm a product lead on the
immersive computing platform
team at Google.
And we're going to
talk to you guys
a little bit about
augmented reality.
Before I do that though,
I'd like to ask everyone,
please silence your
portable telephonic
noisemakers so
that everyone else
can hear the talk
just as clearly
as you can hear your phone.
So thank you so much.
Again, my name is Nathan.
And I want to start with a
very basic observation, which
is that phones have become
dramatically more powerful
over the last decade, right?
We've all seen this happen.
We have dramatically
faster multicore
CPUs, programmable GPUs, more
storage, faster connections.
And all these things have
dramatically changed the way
that we build games on mobile.
But one thing that hasn't really
changed very much in that time
span is actually the
phone's understanding
of the world itself.
If you think about the sensors
that we have on phones today--
camera, GPS, accelerometer--
that's basically
what phones had a decade ago.
Except until actually
very recently, which,
thanks to the
confluence of increasing
onboard compute and
increasing quality in sensors,
we're at the cusp
of what we believe
is going to be the next major
shift in mobile computing,
and that's augmented reality.
By combining the power
of a modern mobile CPU
with advances in machine
learning and computer vision,
we can actually help phones
see and understand the world
the same way that we do.
And as game developers,
that means you finally have
an opportunity to leverage that
understanding to bring digital
information-- your
characters and your IP--
into the real world, right
where it's most accessible
and useful for your players.
So as a game developer,
this is going
to open a lot of
awesome opportunities.
You can fundamentally
blur the boundaries
between the real
world and your game.
You can bring your characters
into the same world
that your players
already inhabit.
You're going to be able
to let players experience
the game from a
different perspective
and actually leverage things
like the position of a device
in space, the physical
structure of the environment
that your player is in, to
create brand new mechanics,
and mechanics that,
in turn, we hope
will spawn entirely new genres.
And because AR is
about the real world,
it's not just about the places,
it's about the people in it.
And you can leverage an
understanding of people
to create interactive
experiences based
on identity expression,
emotional context,
and weave that into the larger
narrative for your game.
We know this to be true
because actually, at Google,
we've been doing smartphone
AR for about four years
now, since 2014.
The challenge, though, is that
historically, smartphones AR
has required a custom
hardware sensor--
we call it Project Tango.
And that custom hardware sensor
limited the rate of adoption
and the rate at which the
ecosystem could scale.
But today, I'm here to talk
to you about a really exciting
opportunity of doing augmented
reality at Android scale,
thanks to a new
technology we call ARCore.
And ARCore is a brand new
augmented reality library
for Android.
And as a developer, it
gives you three foundational
and very powerful capabilities.
The first of them
is motion tracking.
ARCore actually combines
data from the color camera
on your phone with the IMU
to compute a 3D position
and orientation of
the phone in space.
And that's what
actually allows you
to place a digital character and
walk around it, get closer, get
further away, and have that
character feel anchored
in the real world, just like any
other piece of the environment.
But even though
motion tracking lets
you place objects
in the world, you
need to understand the
world itself in order
to create rich interactions.
And so the second
thing we provide,
we call environmental
understanding.
And this is a set
of algorithms that
allow you to do things
like get a sparse point
cloud for the scene, do
ray casts against it,
and even detect really
important components
of the scene, like the
ground, or the table planes.
And with that, you can actually
create your interactions,
do physics, UI, all in a
3D spatially aware context.
The last thing that we provide
is called lighting estimation.
And this is a set
of algorithms that
allows you to understand the
ambient lighting in the room.
So you actually allow
your virtual objects
to feel like they're
lit and shaded
in a way that integrates
with the real world.
And you could even use
it for behavioral cues,
allowing your
characters to respond
to changes in brightness in
the lighting environment.
We know though
that, as developers,
you care not just
about a technology,
you need an audience.
And so I'm very,
very proud to say
that ARCore today runs on
more than 100 million Android
phones.
Many of these are
flagship phones
from all of the major
ODMs in the ecosystem.
So if you build an
ARCore app today,
you can already reach
an audience at scale.
And we're not content to
stop with 100 million phones.
This year, we're partnering with
the entire Android ecosystem,
many more OEMs, to
significantly increase
that number of supported devices
over the course of the year.
And we know also,
that a lot of you
are now thinking about
bringing your games not
just to the established
developed markets,
but to China, which may
be new for a lot of you,
but seen as a new opportunity.
And so we're very
happy to announce
that we're going to be
bringing ARCore to China
later this year, in partnership
with three really key OEMs,
Huawei, Xiaomi, and Samsung.
Now all this stuff is great.
But you're developers,
you actually
want to make apps and games.
And to do that, you need SDKs.
And we have SDKs for every
IDE that you care about.
So if you're a C programmer
working on your own game
engine, we've got you covered.
You want to do Java
app development,
we've got an SDK for that.
Or if you like a commercial game
engine like Unity or Unreal,
we have really high
quality native integrations
built in close partnerships
with both Unity and Epic.
And all of this
is going to allow
you to build your own app
really efficiently, effectively,
and deploy it to an
audience that's already
over 100 million devices large.
Speaking of that, I want to talk
a little bit about some tips
and tricks, things
that we've learned
about how to build
AR-enabled apps efficiently
and effectively.
And these are all things
that I hope all of you
are thinking about, ready to
get started building an app.
And these will hopefully help
you avoid some common pitfalls,
save you time, make
you more effective.
So on the design side, a
few tips we want to share.
The first and most
fundamental is
that anyone building an
ARCore app really, really
wants to think about
your onboarding flow.
For your players, ARCore
is a brand new modality.
Even basic things like,
you can walk around,
are new ideas to your players.
So make sure that
you really invest
in onboarding that's
natural for your game,
so that your players feel
comfortable and at home,
and actually get the most
out of this new modality.
The other-- the
second thing you want
to think about a
lot in design is
the scale of your experience.
And most ARCore
experiences are going
to fall into one of two buckets,
either a table scale or room
scale.
Table scale is great for,
basically, tabletop gaming.
It's a very predictable
environment, right?
Most people's tables
are of a similar size.
They tend to not
have much clutter.
They're all at a uniform height.
And if you want a very, kind
of predictable experience,
tabletop is a natural way to go.
Room scale is kind
of the opposite.
Rooms have a greater
diversity of objects.
They have multiple planes
at multiple heights.
There might be a table
in the room that's
just part of the play surface.
And this has a lot of
creative opportunity,
in the same way that it
has technical complexity.
And so when you think
about your experience,
try to decide upfront, are
we fundamentally building
a room scale, or fundamentally
building a table scale
experience?
As you think about either
one of these things,
you're going to wind up
placing virtual objects that
need to feel anchored
in the real world.
And there's actually a
technical concept called anchors
in all of our ARCore SDKs.
And for you developers and
programmers in the room, what
you want to really
be careful about is,
every time you say, ah, this
is a virtual object that
needs to make a really tight
connection to something
in the physical
world, you always
want to programmatically
create an anchor at that point.
And once you do that, our
underlying motion tracking
algorithms will make sure
that it stays fixed in space,
even as the camera moves, even
as the lighting changes, all
that sort of stuff.
And of course, once you've
placed these objects,
you want them to be believable.
A lot of what we do is we create
believable synthetic realities.
And in AR, that means that your
characters need to not just be
lit well, they need to
be lit well in a way that
matches the environment.
You need to establish a
physical and visual identity
consistent with the environment
that the player is in.
And players can be
in any environment
in the real world, which
is a pretty amazing amount
of diversity.
So there's really two things
you want to think about--
shadowing and lighting,
in that order.
With shadowing,
fundamentally, contact shadows
are what establish
the visual connection
between a virtual object
and the physical world.
And so you really
want to make sure
that you think about a good
contact shadow, or self shadow,
in your ambient
occlusion solution,
so that wherever your
character's feet are,
or tentacles, or you know,
paws, whatever they are,
that they're actually
making contact
with the ground and
the world around them.
And the second is the shading
on that character itself.
You want to think about
physically-based rendering
and image-based
lighting as a way
to ensure that the shading
model on the object
matches the real world
and that the lighting
that the real world sees
is the same one that's
applied to your character.
And we've got some great samples
of all this stuff online.
So now to get into
building your app,
a few things I
want to highlight.
First off, we know
for many of you,
especially when
you're prototyping,
or if you're an indie developer,
mobile-friendly 3D assets
are a big challenge.
Well, we have an entire
site called Poly,
with thousands of free very,
very royalty-friendly--
I'm sorry,
license-friendly 3D assets.
Bruno, after me, is going to go
into this in a lot of detail.
But definitely check
out Poly to help
yourself get off the ground.
We have runtime SDKS
and APIs for it.
It's pretty awesome.
You need to iterate
quickly, right?
You actually want to
try your ideas out.
And in some cases, you want to
try your ideas out in a room
that you don't have available
to you at your desk.
So we've actually extended
the Android Emulator
that comes with Android Studio
with support for ARCore.
So you can actually build an app
and test on a virtual AR device
without leaving the
comfort of your desk,
even though it takes you
to an entirely other place.
And this lets you
iterate in your core game
loop, your core ideas, within
seconds, rather than minutes.
It's pretty awesome.
And then the last two I'll talk
about is graphics debugging.
AR is a fundamentally
visual medium,
and as you get into especially
the lighting and shading,
you're going to want to
debug your graphics pipeline
and understand what's
going on under the hood.
So we've built a
tool called GAPID,
which allows you to
quickly visualize, inspect,
and diagnose your rendering
in a way that's independent
of the underlying hardware.
So regardless of whether you
have an Exynos or Qualcomm,
or whatever-based phone,
GAPID will work on it,
with ARCore active.
So the last thing I
want to talk about
is actually launching your app.
Of course, that's the
most important part,
and there's two main
modalities in ARCore.
We call them AR Required
and AR Optional.
So the simplest model
is an AR Required app.
And if you say, no matter what,
my app fundamentally requires
ARCore, doesn't make
sense without it,
you're an AR Required app.
And for you, when you configure
your manifest for AR Required,
on the Play Store,
we'll actually
make sure that only
ARCore certified devices
can see that app listing entry.
So you don't have
to worry about users
downloading it and not
being able to use it.
And in fact, for
those users, we'll
bundle the core AR services in
with the download of your app,
so that as soon as that
download is finished,
the user is ready to play.
You don't need to do any extra
initialization or checking.
You can just get started.
Many of you, though,
are going to want
to use AR in an optional
fashion as an enhancement
to an app that runs on a
wider variety of platforms,
maybe the entirety of
the Android ecosystem.
And for you, we have the
similar manifest settings,
where you can say, I support
ARCore, but it's optional.
And what you'll need to
use is some APIs in our SDK
that allow you to check to see,
is this device ARCore capable,
are the ARCore
services installed?
And if it is capable, but
they're not installed,
we actually have a
nice pop-up dialog box
where users can
install those services
without leaving your app.
So you're not giving up traffic,
you're not losing engagement.
You're still able to
add ARCore at scale.
Kind of whichever
modality you want to use.
And of course we're all
gamers here, right, not just
game developers.
And if you want to experience
ARCore for yourself,
live today, we have over
100 apps on the Play Store
that are all built
on top of ARCore,
built from some of
the best developers.
In fact, I think a number
of people in this room
are part of this list.
So go to the Play
Store, check out ARCore,
and you'll find a number
of great, really, really
exciting, innovative apps
and games to check out.
So with that, I want
to thank you very much,
and hand it over to Bruno.
[APPLAUSE]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Thanks, Nathan.
All right.
So we're going to talk
about the Poly API.
When I was a kid, I always
liked to develop games.
I think games is something
that I've always been doing.
And, well, this was back
in the times of BASIC.
And my friends and
I would get together
and we would try to
make a bunch of games.
We kind of knew the
programming part,
but we really had some
difficulty with the art.
So often, we would
come up with a game,
and then we would have
like this nice code,
but then we would
imagine-- oh, imagine
this really epic
dragon comes out
at the player on this scene.
But the reality of our graphics
were something more like that.
[LAUGHTER]
Sometimes you can
work around that.
You know, sometimes you can
say, oh, that's not a dragon.
That's more like
a slug like thing.
Sometimes you can work
around that stuff.
But other times, you can't.
So I'm the kind of developer
who really likes cubes.
So with my skills,
I could develop
a game that's about a cube that
shoots other cubes to protect
those bigger cubes
from being hit
by the smaller cubes against
a background of cubes.
You should think that there's no
way that that's a viable game.
You would be wrong.
I introduce you to Cubic Pilot.
Not only is this thing
a thing, but Google,
in some official
capacity, actually
endorsed it, because it's a
sample for the Play Games API.
What I'm saying
with this is that,
we, as developers,
we all have the book.
And we have all read that book.
And I have that--
and we know that sometimes
the best way to do--
sometimes the only
way to do games
is to apologize for
some lack of graphics.
So some people,
when I show this,
what they tell me is, have
you heard about something
called money?
And I'm like, no,
tell me about it.
And they say, well, money
is this magical thing
that you can exchange
for goods and services.
For example, if you don't
have assets, then instead
of reading that book, you can
go and exchange your money
for some assets that
somebody else has made.
That's how the economy works.
And I say, well,
that's interesting,
but this is a traditional
asset acquisition model.
And there are some problems
with that traditional asset
acquisition model.
One of them is that
it requires money.
The second problem with
that asset acquisition model
is cats.
And by that, of course,
I mean, if you ever
actually tried to
buy assets online,
you can't just buy one cat.
That's not a thing.
You have to buy
Super Deluxe Cat Pack
2000 with 700 fully-rigged
animated cats for a very
high price.
And I have nothing against cats,
but 700 might be a bit much.
Third reason is prototyping.
Sometimes, you're still in the
prototyping phase of your game.
At this point, I
might not really
know if I want to make
a game about cats,
or spaceships, or maybe
cats that fly spaceships.
Who knows?
But anyway, I'm not ready to
commit to any particular cat,
much less 700 of them.
And the fourth
reason is runtime.
What happens if you've
never actually thought
about cats at all during
development, and now
at runtime, the
user wants a cat?
Of all times, now they want it.
So how do you actually
load a cat at runtime?
This is why I like Poly.
So Poly is Google's
gallery of 3D assets,
and there's everything there.
So if you are a developer
making a game, you can go there,
and you can find assets
for pretty much everything.
If your game has cups of
coffee, if your game has knives,
if your game has cameras,
space shuttle capsules,
if your game in any
way involves mustaches,
you're going to find
everything there.
And how do those awesome
assets get there?
Well, users can upload
them from Blocks--
which is our 3D VR
asset creation app--
from Tilt Brush, and people
can also upload OBJ files
that they've made using Blender,
Maya, and other programs.
Even I made my own contribution
there, as you can see.
So if you ever need a
cube, you're covered.
Just use that one.
[LAUGHTER]
And all of that comes at the--
I'm sure you'll find
very reasonable price--
of nothing, zero dollars.
And if you mention this
talk, you get a 50% discount.
[LAUGHTER]
And the assets are free,
and they are licensed.
Most of them are licensed
under Creative Commons, which
means you can use them
for free in your app,
and then all you have to do
is give appropriate credit
to the authors.
So Poly is great.
How do we get that
stuff in your app?
So it came to our attention
that developers love APIs.
So we decided, why don't
we have an API for Poly?
That makes sense, right?
So we put together our
most creative minds
to come up with a name for this.
What are we going to
call this API for Poly?
And what we came up
with was Poly API.
So you can find all
about it on that URL.
So it's an API
that lets you load
those assets into your app.
But what can that API do?
So for example, this is
an example from ANIMVR.
As you can see, you
can, at runtime,
find out a bunch of assets.
And then it can import
them into a scene,
and then let the user use
them to create the scene.
So how does the
API actually work?
Whenever you make a
request to that API,
it's going to be handled
by one of our blue robots
in the data center.
That's an actual picture of
what's going on in the server
right now.
And so you can use that API
to find the assets you want.
You can specify
keyword, you can specify
category type, complexity
of any format that you want.
And then of course-- and this
is probably the important part--
you can download
the assets and then
import them into your scene.
There's also a curation flag.
So the curation
flag is something
that indicates that the
asset has been evaluated
by a human being in our
team, not a blue robot,
and that it has been
determined to be a good asset.
So if you want to filter
for only good assets,
you can use that curation flag.
It's the same flag that
filters the web page.
The API is naturally
cross-platform.
It's basically a
REST API, so you
can access it from
basically any device that
can do internet connections.
If you're using
Unity or Unreal, we
do have Poly Toolkit, which
is a full fledged tool
kit for the engine
that wraps up the API
and has some convenience helper
methods that can do everything
from the queries to
importing and downloading.
And if you're not
using Unity or Unreal,
we also have samples for
many of the other platforms.
So Android, ARCore, iOS,
SceneKit, ARKit, Web--
so we have samples
for all of those.
So this is what
the API looks like.
It's basically
just a GET request.
It has a bunch of parameters.
So you can specify the key words
that you want to search for,
if you want curated stuff or
not, and so on and so forth,
just a GET API.
What you get back is a JSON
file containing a description
of the assets that we found.
And then it has URLs to
download the actual files that
make up that asset.
So this is the workflow.
Just list the assets, find
out the kind of assets
that you want, then
decide which ones
you want to import, then
download the asset files,
and display the
asset in your scene.
It's a pretty
straightforward workflow.
This is an example of
Poly Toolkit running.
So you're going to see
that, in Unity, you
have this editor window
where you can select assets.
And then you can click and
import them into your scene
directly from the Unity UI.
This is an example of
importing this garden directly
from the Unity UI.
It takes about three
clicks to do that,
and then you have that
garden in your scene.
There's also the runtime
API on the Poly Toolkit.
So it's pretty much what you
would expect a C# API to be
like.
This is a request, for example,
to get some random cats.
And if you run that
with the keyword "cat,"
you get random cats.
You can also be very specific.
Like if you're very, very
picky in your taste for cats,
you can specify any of
the filters you want,
and then you're going to get
such gems as fancy, fancy cat,
space cat, creative
cat, galactic cat,
and a bunch of other ones.
And there's a lot of
flexibility on the kinds of apps
that you can build.
For example, you can
build standalone apps,
you can build VR apps,
you can build AR apps.
So these low poly models
are great for AR apps.
So if you're using
ARCore, that's
a great way to load assets.
We actually made a couple
of games with this.
This is an escape-the-room game
that we made with this API.
So it's pretty much like,
you're stuck in a room in VR,
and then you have to
go and escape the room
by solving the puzzles.
It's a very cheesy game.
And you can see that
you can use the objects,
and add some lighting,
and you can already
create some very
interesting effects with it.
This is another one.
You might want to create
this atmospheric VR
game where you have to--
like, in this misty landscape.
And then you have to go up
the stairs and find this cat.
And then, I'm not sure.
I didn't really think
this came through.
[LAUGHTER]
But presumably, the cat will
ignore you at that point.
I'm just illustrating
the wide breadth of games
that you can make.
So what this means
for me, of course,
is that I can stop
making games like that.
And hopefully, I can
step up my art assets
and start making games
that are more like that,
all using the Poly API.
So go ahead and check out
developers.google.com/poly
so you can find more
information about our API.
And I'm sure that your
players will like it.
And speaking about
players, you know what's
even better than one player?
More than one player.
So up next, I'd like
to invite Aaron,
who's going to talk about
multiplayer game design.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON CAMMARATA: All right.
Nice job.
Thanks for warming them up.
Here's a question.
Why do we play?
Why do humans and hundreds
of other species play games?
I mean, games are fun
and they're relaxing.
But why have we
evolved to enjoy games?
Well, for decades, scientists
thought the answer was that,
by playing, young animals were
learning the skills that they
would need as adults, hunting,
and stalking, fighting,
and fleeing.
And in the '80s, a
researcher testing this
took some tiger cubs
and separated them
while they were young and
kept them from playing.
And as adults, those cats
could hunt just fine.
But what they could not do,
and what they could never
learn to do, was to be social.
You see, play is not how
we learn physical skills.
Play is how we
learn social skills.
You see, survival is not
a single player game.
A strong social system
is critical to succeeding
in the wild, and play
offers us a safe place
to build and nurture
our relationships.
Ask anyone in a long-term
relationship and they
will tell you, play
is critical to love.
So if social skills
are the "why" of play,
then as designers, we need to
deeply understand the "how"
of human relationships.
And that journey
starts with a number.
Our social networks are
surprisingly consistent.
Around the world, we
all have about 150
stable and meaningful
relationships.
And after that, we actually
run out of brainpower.
Each new person
that we try to add
pushes somebody
else out the back.
It's known as Dunbar's number--
and I see a few of you
nodding in recognition--
after the scientist
who discovered it.
Of course, not all friendships
are created equally.
We separate our relationships
into different levels,
and they're sorted by trust.
The more I trust
you, the more I'm
willing to invest
in our relationship,
and the more willing I am to
show you my innermost self.
This has the somewhat
unfortunate name
of the social
penetration theory,
and it too is remarkably
consistent around the world.
All of us have about
five best friends
that we trust implicitly.
Around that, we have a
larger ring of friends,
about 15, who we trust,
but not quite as much.
And then a ring of 45 to 50,
and then that final ring of 150.
And these layers are
very clearly separated
from their neighbors,
defined by how much we
trust the people in each group.
This is the fundamental
truth of our social lives.
First, we explore
safe topics together,
to see if we like the same
food, or music, or games.
Then we learn to
rely on one another.
And finally, we learn
to trust one another.
And trust is the lifeblood
of a relationship.
So I wondered, if this is
the scientifically proven arc
and structure of
human relationships,
then as designers,
could we learn
to use this to build a
better multiplayer game?
Well, I've actually been at
Google for around two years,
working on this problem.
Along the way, I asked
Raph Koster about this,
and he was intrigued
by the concept
and agreed to join me in
trying to find an answer.
Together, we made a list of
about 200 game mechanics.
And for each one, we asked, how
much trust does this call for?
The result, based
on the answer, we
mapped it to each of the
stages of human relationship.
And the result is a map
from real human trust
to game mechanics.
It's a brand new
design lens that I'm
proud to share with you today
for the first time ever,
and we call it the
trust spectrum.
By building games that support
relationships at all levels,
we found we could provide much
stickier and more compelling
games for our players.
What's more, because we
worked with the grain
of human relationships as they
truly exist in the real world,
people left the
games feeling more
connected than they did before.
So let me show you how.
First, we took these stages
that become more intimate as you
move up the scale, and laid
that across a new chart, left
to right, like this.
As we started to analyze
this big pile of mechanics
we had made, we found that
they clustered into families,
like this.
Remember, each design axis
represents dozens of mechanics
that impact player
trust in similar ways.
For example, let's take
that top row, symmetry,
which is the amount of
overlap in capabilities
that players have in-game.
Now, I'm talking about the rules
of the game, not player skill,
here.
Symmetry is about
whether we can all
do the same things in-game,
or very different things.
At low levels of trust,
everyone can pretty much
do the same thing.
Some of us might have
advantages in different areas,
but any player in any role can
pretty much finish the game.
At the medium
levels of trust, we
get to things like
team-based shooters.
We can all run and
gun, but each character
brings something
unique to the team.
At the highest
levels of trust, you
have almost unique abilities,
like character classes
in RPGs and MOBAs.
At this extreme
level of asymmetry,
you get interdependent
play strategies
like tank, healer, and DPS.
Now remember, every
one of these rows
has the same level of
detail and complexity.
And what's more, they
interact with each other
in subtle and non-linear ways.
So for example, let's
go back to symmetry.
Think of a relaxing
puzzle game where
each player can do something
unique, like open doors,
or pull levers.
And the players can
work together as a team
to solve puzzles
and win the game.
Now contrast that
with an RPG, which
requires strict timing
and precise coordination.
These are both highly
asymmetric games,
but one is a very
low trust experience,
and the other is
extremely high trust.
So I hope by now
you're inspired to go
try some of these ideas
in your multiplayer games.
So let me give you a few
tips on how to get started.
First and most important,
build your game
so that players can
succeed no matter
what stage their relationship.
However, do not incentivize them
to move beyond the playstyle
that suits them.
The goal of the
trust spectrum is not
for players to advance up it.
If you give them points
or otherwise incentivize
them to move up the scale, they
will, and this doesn't work.
We are not wired to be best
friends with everybody.
Second, try to cover
the full spectrum
so there's things to do
for all kinds of players.
If I can play your game
with all of my friends,
then I probably will.
However, be careful not to
mix high trust and low trust
experiences together
at the same time.
It will absolutely
confuse your players.
Third, if you're at a loss
about where to get started,
think about the ways that
players connect in your game,
whether it be through friends
lists, or different game modes.
And then for each of those,
think about how many players
are interacting at once.
If you have, say,
a big boss battle
scene where 150 players can
all pile on and contribute,
you're going to want to
use low trust interactions
between the players.
But if the team sizes
are more like 15, or 5,
then use higher trust mechanics
to create a deeper connection
between those players.
So basically, don't use
high trust mechanics
in large groups.
It's not appropriate
for a big group.
But also, don't use
low trust mechanics
in tight and intimate gameplay.
It's too shallow an experience,
and your players will basically
get bored and disengage.
Finally, for all my producers
out there, be warned.
The higher you go up
the trust spectrum,
the longer it's going to
take to make your game.
A high trust game, we
found, can take three
to four times as long to
make as a low trust game.
And this largely comes
from that asymmetry
that I was talking about.
A fully asymmetric
game is like building
multiple single-player
experiences, each of which
needs to be balanced
and perfect.
But they also need to
work together as a system.
And finally, don't forget
to check for interactions
between your systems.
We actually found it was pretty
easy to use two low trust
systems or mechanics that
interfered with one another,
and accidentally created
high trust experiences.
So here's a few more
resources to keep you going.
First, Raph has graciously
agreed to share,
in great detail--
I'm talking 11,000
word blog post
on his site, raphkoster.com.
Of course, others have
gone before on this path,
in particular I call out
the Project Horseshoe
report on this topic, which
takes a slightly different
angle on the same subject.
And I also hear Dan Cook is
giving a talk on this topic
at 4:00 PM on Thursday,
which I know I will be at.
Multiplayer makes
games stickier.
Stickier games have higher
engagement and more replay.
So using the trust spectrum,
you can build games
that help players
meet new people
and nurture their relationships.
So I'd like to leave you
with the question, what
if you could build
games that are not
just good for your bottom
line, they're good for gamers?
And if you'd like to talk
about this some more,
I will be at the Google booth
on Thursday from 12:00 to 3:00.
And up next, I'd like to
welcome Maria to the stage,
from Daydream.
She's going to bring up
some of our partners,
and they're going to share their
experience making AR games.
And I thank you very
much for listening
[APPLAUSE]
MARIA ESSIG: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hi, everyone.
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Hello.
MARIA ESSIG: Really excited to
see all of you joining us today
for our wonderful conversation.
Thanks for making time.
My name is Maria Essig.
I work at Daydream team focusing
on gaming vertical across VR
and AR platforms.
And actually, today, our
team shaped an AR destination
on Google Play Store, where you
can find multiple experiences
across gaming utilities,
self-expression,
and other verticals,
highlighting new developers
and someone who actually
has experience working
in this space to delight
you, to bring new characters
and interest in games
to the world around you.
I'm honored to introduce
my speaker to you today.
Her name is Samantha Gorman.
Samantha's works extends across
narrative, cinema, games,
virtual reality, and
media scholarship.
Samantha is a co-founder
on the indie art
collective Tender
Claws, who are working
on mobile apps such as PRY, who
delivered a wonderful mobile VR
experience called Virtual,
Virtual Reality, actually
one of the most acknowledged
mobile VR games today.
And besides being busy
at Tender Claws, shaping
all the great
experiences, Samantha
holds a master of
Fine Arts degree
in writing for
digital media, and can
be found at the University
of Southern California
completing her PHD in
media arts and practice.
So we're all talking that AR
is quite new, that it's just
coming to the market.
But you, Samantha, actually
worked with this medium
for quite a long time.
Can you share with the audience
what originally brought
to you to this medium, and share
your probably first project?
What was it?
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
So when Google Glass
was first announced,
I actually did a
performance piece
at the Geffen Contemporary,
which is this museum in LA,
with this poet
named Vanessa Place.
And we used the capabilities of
Glass to record the audience,
project it back to
themselves, and then augment
that projection with funny
search queries for, like,
"OK, Glass," that we're in the
text of what we were using.
And I think my interest in
AR was coming from the fact
that I think there's a
lot of really awesome use
cases for, you know, room scale
and environmental storytelling.
But what does it mean when you
can be in the room with someone
live, and you can actually
have an AR layer of information
about that person, or
maybe some thoughts
about what they
could be feeling?
How does that change
the dynamics of you
and the other person in
your actual physical space
as a player?
MARIA ESSIG: Wow, that's
really interesting.
And your team was constantly
experimenting with this medium,
and actually emphasizing
this connection
between live dialogue, people,
and the new technology.
Speaking of which, you've
just premiered your new title,
called TendAR, during
Sundance festival.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
what inspired you here,
more about this project
and your plans for it?
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Yeah, sure.
So TendAR is actually
a social AR experience,
sort of going off of
the original interest
with that Google Glass project.
And it uses a
front-facing camera
to put a filter on the face
of you and your partner,
give some kind of
information about the room
and what you're feeling.
And then that is turned
into fish food, which
is fed to an AI fish
that evolves over time,
depending on the emotion
flakes you feed it.
MARIA ESSIG: Oh, wow.
So much emotion.
How does fish react to
different experiences?
How it goes with the flow?
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Yeah,
it depends on what mood
he's in at the time.
MARIA ESSIG: Wait, so
technically, we have AR cat
version, but in the fish.
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Yes.
MARIA ESSIG: By the
way, for everyone,
we have TendAR as
one of the AR demos
at Google booth
in southern hall.
Booth number 823.
So if you have time,
highly recommend
you to check it out and
see how AR brings people
closer to each other.
Speaking of the technological
part of the game,
it's pretty much packed with
different new platform features
and design decisions.
How was your experience
working with ARCore?
Was the toolset actually
helpful to deliver
on your creative vision?
SAMANTHA GORMAN:
I meant to say--
and this is actually
related to that question--
that the TendAR
version at the booth
is a companion piece to the full
app, which is single player,
and has AR content that unfolds
over multiple play sessions.
And that is related because
we had to really think
about how to put the characters
and models into the space that
was meaningful for the
player's environment.
And ARCore actually took
care of that technology
really easy and simply for us.
Which then made it so that a
lot of the outstanding questions
were actually design decisions
in terms of like, OK,
we have a character in space.
But we just don't want
it to think about the--
we want it to know
that the space it's in
is the player's
world space, and not
imagine it as anything else.
So how do we have that
character meaningfully
interact with the
player's world, and what
type of knowledge
can we give it about,
not just the dimensions
of the space,
but what might be in-- like,
what objects or things might
be in the world of the player.
MARIA ESSIG: Oh, great.
Yeah, that's fantastic.
So given your current
experience and all the knowledge
in this space, what do you
think the best and most exciting
applications of AR in,
like, short term, mid term,
long term?
SAMANTHA GORMAN:
I would say I've
seen some really cool, like--
there's been some really
cool tabletop games.
But a lot of the really
interesting things I've seen
are about, like, enterprise,
designing for enterprise,
and being able to really
pick apart and get
the dimensions of objects.
And in the long
term, I think how
we've adapted cell phone use.
In the US, sort of
overnight, it seems
like it's become a mode of
how we interact with our world
and engage with our world,
without us thinking about it
too much.
I think in long term,
they'll probably
be elements of AR
applications or hardware
that will be able to
do that, and we'll just
have informational
layers, you know,
without even analyzing it.
MARIA ESSIG: Yeah, it's
always inspirational
to hear about your
work and your thoughts.
Thanks a lot for joining
us today and for your time.
For everyone, once
again, stop by our booth,
play some great games.
And if you have any
questions to me or Samantha,
feel free to stop
by after the talk.
Thank you, and
right now, I would
like to welcome
Clementine on stage
from our Maps Team, who will
tell you a little bit more
what are other ways to
bring games to real world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMANTHA GORMAN: Thanks.
CLEMENTINE JACOBY: All right.
Does my mic work?
Now it does.
Hello, my name is Clementine.
And as the slide says,
I work for Google Maps.
All right.
Raise your hand if you
have ever played Pong.
Excellent.
OK, now I want you
to think in your head
about how you would describe
the game world in Pong.
Not the game, but
the game world.
So this is really
where gaming started,
with two-dimensional
experiences,
where the game world was
really a single screen.
Later, we evolved to still
two-dimensional, but much more
complex game worlds,
where that single screen
became one of many, part
of a larger game world.
And today, there is an
ever increasing demand
for realistically-modeled
3D environments
on a bigger and bigger scale.
Now over the last 40 years,
innovations in technology
have enabled a huge
increase in the ambition
in scope and detail of the
game worlds that we see.
And in response,
games and game worlds
have dramatically increased in
interactivity, in complexity,
and in just sheer
breadth and size.
Some of those games, like you
saw, have become era defining
and brought the industry
along with them.
But fundamentally,
game developers
spend a lot of time and energy
and money modeling game worlds.
And they do this
because, in part,
the detail and dynamism
of your game world
defines how good your
game will end up being.
So as it turns out,
at Google Maps,
we also spend a lot
of time modeling
a world for our
users to explore.
We spend a lot of
time doing this,
and we know it really well.
And we know that when
you do this by hand,
it can produce
breathtaking results,
but it's also
breathtakingly expensive.
And it's getting more
and more expensive
as we try to do this on
bigger and bigger scales.
So think about, for example,
the world in Grand Theft Auto
5, which is still one of the
biggest and richest game worlds
that's ever been created.
At launch, that game
world was about as big
as downtown Manhattan.
So what if we could scale the
art of creating game worlds?
What if there could be game
worlds in which detailed didn't
have to be balanced with size?
All right, now hold that
thought for a moment.
In parallel to that
whole progression,
mobile phones have
gotten really good,
which you've seen in
other talks today, right?
They're getting so
good that developers
can begin to sort of blur
the lines between a game
world and the real world.
And across the mobile
ecosystem, we're
seeing digital content brought
into the physical world.
And this is being
done by smartphones
that are so powerful that
they can convincingly
blend realities.
And at Google Maps, we
specialize in reality.
So for over a decade now,
we've been relentlessly combing
the world, finding
all of its details,
and delivering those
details to you on your phone
so that you can explore,
no matter where you are.
All right, so backing up.
Looking at these two
progressions, we at Google Maps
decided we could help.
And that's why we set out to
create an offering specifically
for gaming, to help developers
build game worlds based
on the real world, powered
by Google Maps data
and backed by Google
Maps infrastructure.
Our goal is to turn the real
world into your playground
so that you can take
that richness of reality
as your starting point
and go from there.
So I'm going to show you a
short video to sort of kick off
what this means.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
I really like the dragon.
So with this product, we
wanted to both help developers
take their game worlds
to the next level,
but also make it
easy to get started,
because geodata is
really complicated.
So we went and talked to
tons and tons of developers
and we built a product
based on what we heard.
And what we heard,
loud and clear,
was that you basically wanted
help with three things.
So first, you need access
to Google Maps data,
that rich and accurate and
living model of the real world.
So critically, our
data is really fresh.
We make about 25
million updates a day
to reflect the pace at
which the world is changing.
And that data relies on
the same infrastructure,
in this case, as the
billions of requests
made to Google Maps a day.
Second-- and this was something
that we heard resoundingly--
you wanted that data in Unity.
So we built an SDK that does
all the heavy lifting for you,
no Google Maps expertise
needed to get started.
And this allows
your team to focus
on doing what they do
best, which is creating
a rich and immersive game.
And third-- and this
one's really important,
because it's really hard--
we help you design interactions
around real world places.
So note that this is a
monumental challenge.
Like, think for a
moment about where
you would end a
mission in a suburb
that you had never
been to before
on the other side of the world.
It's really hard,
and doing it well
requires knowing a lot about the
player's immediate environment
and also their larger context.
So we help you design gameplay
around real world locations
so that you can choose places
that are appropriate, unique,
and fun to play, no matter
where your players are.
Now we're going to take a
look at how to build a game.
So I'm going to bring Patrick
up on stage to show you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
I'm Patrick Donelan, engineering
lead for Google Maps APIs.
I'm super excited to
be talking to you today
about what we've
been working on.
So imagine that you're building
your very own location-based
game.
The first thing that
you're going to need
is high-quality map data.
As Clementine mentioned,
we're bringing
Google's rich, accurate,
living model of the real world
into Unity.
I'd like to show you exactly
what that looks like.
So if we roll the video,
what you're seeing here
is Manhattan rendered
by the Maps Unity SDK
inside of a demo app that we
put together for this talk.
Our SDK makes it really easy
to turn this blank canvas
into a stylized
game environment.
Here's an example.
So notice how
custom textures have
been applied to buildings,
parks, and roads
to create a futuristic
look and feel.
Our SDK gives you fine grained
control of this process
by modeling each map feature
as a separate game object.
So what was previously
a bland street corner
is now the setting for
a sci-fi adventure.
Or, if you prefer fantasy,
the same real world location
could be just as easily
turned into a medieval scene,
or anything else
that you dream up.
Every game object is
annotated with rich metadata,
allowing you to make
styling decisions based
on the real world.
For example, if we
roll the video--
here we go.
OK, so you can turn, for
example, shops into chocolate
bars, or buildings
into restaurants,
or change the
heights of buildings.
Through simple
customizations such as these,
you can create unique game
environments that still feel
connected to the real world.
OK, so now that
we've established
the look and feel
of our game, let's
add some location-based
gameplay.
For example, let's add
missions and spawn points
at prominent locations
around the world.
The playable
locations API lets you
build your game once and have it
work anywhere around the world.
We use a vast array
of Google Maps
signals to determine the best
places for gameplay and AR
experiences ranked by
prominence and popularity.
You can request points
at whatever density
your game requires
and fine tune the way
that those points are
distributed in a way that
is unique to your game.
Let me show you a visualization
of how this works.
So the green dots that
you are seeing here
are playable locations
around the player.
Lets turn the most prominent
of these into mission points
so that people have
somewhere nearby that's
recognizable to play.
Here, we are going to represent
missions as rainbow arches,
just to fit with the
theme of the game.
OK.
The playable locations API
also includes rich metadata,
so you can customize
the type of game play
that you associate
with each location.
For example, you could
put virtual candy stands
in real world store locations.
Or as another example, you could
spawn gummy bear characters
at restaurants.
And these might be a
really great choice
for your multiplayer
experiences,
since people tend to meet
up in groups at restaurants.
And if instead you are
creating a fantasy game,
these could instead have been
dragons and treasure chests.
Or if it was a
futuristic game, it
could be spaceships
and floating loot.
Whatever your game,
you get to focus
on the fun part of creating
rich, engaging gameplay
based on the real world.
Keep in mind that all of this
is happening inside of Unity.
And so if I was
to press stop, you
would see that the scene is
empty, because everything
is generated on the fly.
We include lots
of other features
to help you build your
game, such as nine-slicing
for applying custom textures
to arbitrarily sized buildings,
and decorators for adding
parapets and other geometry
the tops of
buildings, or borders
around roads and buildings for
simulating ambient occlusion
contact shadows.
We give you access to the
names of roads and buildings,
and integrate with Unity's
lighting and skybox systems
so you can create a
beautiful day night cycle.
We also support Unity's
level of detail system,
automatically fading
out distant geometry
to maximize mobile performance.
And finally, you have access
to Unity's physics engine,
allowing you to use the
world's geometry in any 3D
physics-based game.
OK, enough about features.
Next I want to show
you some examples
of just how far you can push
this platform that we've
created.
So the technique used
to create this scene
is a little different to
the previous examples.
Instead of applying
custom textures,
procedural rules were used
to assemble a high resolution
city out of modular
asset packs, based
on the real world's layout.
Down below, you can see cars
driving along roads, bus stops,
lampposts, power lines.
As we zoom in, you start to see
just how detailed the street
level is.
There's trees, cafe
tables, shopfronts,
people walking around.
Even though the
technique used here
is much more sophisticated, it's
the same rich, semantic model
of the real world provided
by the Maps Unity SDK that
makes all this possible.
Let's look at another example.
So even though this
scene looks a little
different to the
previous one, it's
actually using the
same technique, just
with a different set of assets.
The way that the buildings
work here is really cool.
They self-assemble themselves
out of modular components
using all of the metadata
provided by the Maps Unity SDK,
creating, in essence, a
stylistic interpretation
of the real world.
Or to put it another
way, the cityscape
is grown organically to
match the real world.
What's amazing is
that these examples
were created by a single
developer in only a few weeks.
His name is Adam Goodrich
of Procedural Worlds.
As you can see, he
was able to achieve
an incredible level of detail
in such a short amount of time.
Let's look at one more
example before we move on.
So this is a road running
through Glacier National
Park in Montana.
The trees, rocks, and
clumps of vegetation
were procedurally
generated down to the level
of individual blades of grass.
Elevation data was combined
with the Maps Unity SDK
to create a vast open world,
complete with rivers and lakes,
mountains, towns
in the distance,
animals, wilderness areas.
What I love about
this final example
is it shows that you're not just
limited to busy urban centers
when creating rich,
engaging game worlds.
And with that, I'm going to
hand you back to Clementine.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Patrick.
We need to go back one slide.
Excellent.
So to summarize,
Patrick sort of--
he showed you four
things that we
want to help developers with.
The first is we want you to be
able to build your game once
and then make it
interesting everywhere
in the world at global scale.
So you'll have
access to hundreds
of millions of 3D buildings,
points of interest, roads,
rivers, landmarks,
cafes, et cetera,
to form the foundation
of your game world.
And this all relies on that
same model of the world
that Google Maps has
been building since 2005.
So you'll have accurate and
fresh data, no matter where
your players are.
The second piece
is that we want you
to be able to completely
customize this game world.
So you can turn rivers
into lava flows,
or fill parks with trees,
or oceans with waves.
You just saw a huge range
of examples of things
that have already been done.
You can do simple things, like
customize colors or textures,
but you can also swap
in entire prefabs
like you're seeing here.
Third, we want to help
you design gameplay
around real world places.
Find the right locations
for each type and category
of mission, or player,
or in-game reward.
You could drive your
players to popular places
like restaurants,
and town squares,
or take them off
the beaten path.
And the choice is yours.
Either way, we want to help you
deliver an experience that's
unique to your game
and fits your gameplay
anywhere in the world.
And finally, we want to help
deliver these really rich
experiences at global scale.
So relying on Google's
infrastructure
will mean faster response
times, scale on demand,
and also just the
peace of mind that
comes with knowing that
your game will just work.
So that's an overview.
The last video I
want to show you
is a bit of what developers
are already doing with this.
So last year, we started
a trusted tester program.
And we've been working with some
of the top mobile developers
in this space who wanted
to launch real world
games starting this year.
Today, I'm going to show
you three of those games.
So first up, we have
Jurassic World Alive.
This is the second installment
of Ludia's Jurassic World
Series, and it's been
created in partnership
with Universal Studios.
So in this game, as
you explore the world,
you're also hunting dinosaurs.
And you're collecting
their DNA so
that you can clone them and
create your own dinosaurs.
[MUSIC - RAY PARKER JR.,
"GHOSTBUSTERS"]
[PHONE RINGING]
So next up, we have
Ghostbusters World.
This is a location-based
AR collection game.
So this game features
first-person shooter mechanics,
and you can also interact with
other players in real time
as you explore the world and
collect and capture ghosts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, last up, we have
the Walking Dead, Our World,
which is based on AMC's
mega-hit and being
built by an Next Games.
This is a location-based
AR survival game.
In this game, players
explore the world,
fight walkers, form alliances
with other survivors,
and build safe havens.
All of these games
are coming soon
to the real world near you,
along with many others.
So expect 2018 to be a big
year for real world gaming.
We're really excited
to play these games
and also to see
what you will build.
For every game, we're going to
be bringing the full support
of Google to bear.
Google is very invested in AR
technology and betting big.
We're really excited
to partner with ARCore
to bring their expertise
to our gaming partners.
In fact, all of the three
games that you just saw
have ARCore powered gameplay.
We're also collaborating
with other key teams
at Google who are focused
on gaming-- for example,
Google Cloud for your
game server needs
and YouTube and Play
for promotional help.
Fundamentally, we
want to make it easier
to launch games that move
the industry forward,
and the rest of
Google wants to help.
So if you're
building a game that
features real world elements,
please come talk to us.
You can head over to our
website, which is listed here,
and fill out the
contact sales form,
and our team will get in
touch to get you started.
There's also a lot
of opportunities
to talk to our team
during this week at GDC.
If you want to learn
more and get a chance
to talk in more detail,
please stop by our talk
on the expo floor on Thursday.
Our team will be there and
we'll be doing Q&A afterwards.
You can also find us
at the Google booth,
where we'll have
demos to play with,
and developers who have
built games with Maps
that you can talk to,
as well as our team.
All right, that's it.
So before we break for lunch,
please copy down this URL
and give us some feedback
on the morning sessions.
And we'll see you
back here after lunch.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]